welcome back y'all just a few years ago
our next guest was a daytime TV producer
for this very company actually now she's
running a hugely successful group of
restaurants called vegan I love
the title she's a Time 100 next onor and
she's got a new book out and it's called
I hope you
fail it's incredible you can find it
wherever books are sold give it up for
Pinky
[Applause]
Cole
hello so cool can I say something oh go
ahead sugar
butter yes that's we should have had you
out here for that you could have at
least done butter and shown them when to
sing kid we could have did a baby dance
at least I I know that's so sweet so
this is third number three for you right
yes yes I have been pregnant for how
long hear this out hear this out I've
been pregnant since 2020 oh my God I'm
so serious 20120 21 22 and now 23 and I
am done respectfully after this oh my
God no I understand that I was like if
you don't take these tubes I'm going to
find you somebody needs to tie them up
but I'm happy um do any day now oh my
gosh that's
incredible oh I love this so you were a
producer here was it Mari for this
compan I was a producer guys for the my
show oh my gosh how did that like how
did the transition happen um so it was
so cool cuz being a producer on the show
obviously like you meet people from all
walks of life and then a friend of mine
was like hey do you want to open up a
restaurant I'm like okay well I never
knew how to cook really but I'll do it
and I opened up my first restaurant in
Harlem New York wait you went from not
really knowing how to cook to owning a
restaurant yeah I like to eat more than
I teach me your way um and I opened up
this first restaurant and it was super
success uccessful and I learned
everything I could about the restaurant
business so like I had lines down the
block and mind you at the time I'm a
vegetarian and I'm selling jerk chicken
and oxtails do as I say not as I do guys
it didn't work um and then I had a
grease fire oh so I lost everything
right can you tell I'm a producer who
like the drama the
high but I had I had a grease fire
seriously I can laugh about it now right
but like at the time I was devastated
and with that grease fire my car got
repoed I got kicked out of my apartment
um like that they could just change your
whole life but I needed that to happen
because it really put me in position to
create this household name that the
world now knows a vegan yeah it
is interesting how something devastating
happens and like what beauty comes out
of that like sometimes um well I want to
try this food so what do we have here
cuz this looks like banana pudding so
this is our sea moss banana pudding yes
and we have our world famous pies let me
take this yes so so this is our homemade
pie world famous um so delicious all
vegan right so there are no bi animal
byproducts no dairy products nothing
I've been for a long time amazing and
this is our sea moss banana pudding this
one of our number one sellers um do you
like it oh my
God would you tell the truth if it was
nasty would you really be like no it's
nasty I don't like it no no no no no no
that is really good people go crazy over
this yeah keep talk and it's a coconut
it's a coconut so here we have a coconut
milk uh based um with that is delicious
I'm glad you like it you can't have that
back that one definitely is St and you
know what's so cool about veganism is
nowadays vegan food tastes better than
the quote unquote real thing that's if
you get good vegan that's cuz you're it
what you're doing it has to be
vegan yeah exactly exactly wait what is
this what's this so that's our world
famous Blackberry Mayo sauce um and you
you're not going to find that sauce
nowhere else right oh my god do you
bottle it can you buy it not yet but I
will and I do have products in Target
stores right now yes okay so you need to
Mom got to pay the bills so we got
revenue coming in from everywhere okay
so coming very very soon yes and all of
this is a result of failing so you know
I I wrote this book called I hope you
fail yeah and it really which is amazing
the title thank you I appreciate it my
last book was called eat plants I
know I
know you got to you got to have it pop
off the shelf yeah you I got to smack
people in the face but I created this
book because I've been through so much
in my life yeah my father did 22 years
in prison um I know what it feels like
to be broke I've been in enough bad
relationships but on the other side of
that I created a multi-million dollar
company that's now valued at 100 million
wow
right and I'm really helping people to
re-engineer when bad things happen
because it's all about your mindset if
you can shift your mindset you can
change the world and that's exactly what
this book is going to do I love that and
I love your food um I'm not kidding
every single thing is going to my
dressing room at the end of this day so
let's do a commercial break I'm probably
going to eat more pinky Cole's new book
is called I hope you fail um you can
find it wherever books are sold and
everyone is going home with a
copy and don't forget to visit pinky
vegan restaurants and food
[Music]
stucks
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home